casting Jack Nicholson in that role yes
you can't handle the truth right you
can't handle the truth what was that
like from your perspective well it was
interesting because you know a big
courtroom and you know Jack has this
long long monologue and I said to him
I'll give you a choice either I can
shoot if you want to shoot ready now
I'll shoot you right now
if you want some time to work on it
rehearse it I will shoot all the
reaction shots first he said why don't
you you know shoot the reaction shots
and that will give me and every time
he's off camera he gives exactly the
same performance that you see that's on
camera after two or three I said I go up
to him and I said Jack you know maybe uh
you want to save a little because I mean
he's full out in every one and he's off
camera and he says rob you don't
understand I love to act
he says I don't get that much of a
chance to do a great part and then we
turn the camera around on him and it was
the same